c'est quoi
comment la morale sa façon de bien se
contenir dans la vie un peu grâce à la
morale qui a que la vie est meilleure
dernièrement et on lance une pote
allemand voilà
elle est nulle elle est nulle qu'est-ce
qu'elle dit ça pourquoi pourquoi
tout le monde pense qu'il veut il y a
personne ne pense la même chose tout il
y a
une drôle différente
réussir dans la vie pour moi c'est
c'est savoir une bonne morale dans la
vie d'un jeune la morale est un peu
moins élevée que ce que la place qu'elle
pouvait
chez un adulte chez un jeune d'autrefois
les gens c'est pas obligé de faire la
morale mais en fait on est comme on est
et puis on a pas besoin de nous dire ce
qu'on a à faire